[Music]
we're closed now yes you like waiting at
the station here Andy this is Bill
remember me please don't change the busy
be so great by what
to work for yourself I know just for fun
I mean how much would it actually cost
about ten thousand fifty all right
fifty thousand nothing could ever came
easy did it you're wasting your time son
I've got time back yeah so my dad is a
very highly skilled bomber so the idea
is to use those skills in in our own
business and we estimate that we could
pay that back within within five years
so what do you think I should take this
[Music]
are you doing
may I present to you obviously it's not
finished yet I still need to get rid of
some of these and this all needs
clearing up as well and there are a lot
of spiders yeah leaflets right any
minute now
um excuse me are you open yes
next morning undie you fancy a haircut
make it quick
so
what know them not go on they're not
gold go
I think column I'll have a bowl cup
please not plating chance
[Music]
you